[Music]
thank you
Jeffrey Bezos nothing is evil in the
beginning thinking you need to start
your show with some wispy Elvish person
sounding all wise and [ __ ] who does she
think she is collateral oh okay well
then
um narration also mosquitoes are
absolutely evil from the start also also
on a philosophical level if there's no
evil in the beginning then there's also
no good moral judgments only exist on a
spectrum of Relativity so stick that in
your church Warden pipe and smoke it
even you could possibly believed their
old scrapbooks being an elevated
Immortal race of creatures who haven't
taught their children how buoyancy works
also we were just told that nothing is
evil from the beginning and here we are
listening to a dick of a kid discourage
a dreamer origami erections do you know
why a ship floats and a stone cannot
because the stone sees only downward
being an elevated Immortal race of
creatures who teach their children that
buoyancy is because rocks have limited
eyesight the ship feels the darkness as
well striving Moment by moment to master
and pull her under wait the ship is
trying to pull itself under the water
elf logic is really confusing but the
[ __ ] has a secret please talk about
scientific evidence please talk about
scientific evidence please talk about
scientific evidence for unlike the stone
okay it's not downward but are fixed
upon the light that guides her that's
not how ships work ah good to see the
elves have invented hair clippers that
can do a nice tight shave above the ear
Well Done by all how am I to know which
lies to follow
feelings into teller chekhov's life
advice as if it's a secret but there's
literally no one else around next time
you're in a conversation alone with just
you and one other person cleaning to
whisper one of the sentences in their
ear and see how natural that feels let's
just get this out of the way right up
front this show may be the most visually
stunning show in the history of
Television granted it costs more than
most movies to make it happen but the
money's on the screen and I'm just
stunned enough to remove a couple of
sins for the multiple eyegasms
throughout we left
our home
and journeyed to a distant realm
establishing all travel by a giant map
and a fantasy property cliche
excuse me you're just gonna throw us
into a war against pretty big birds and
Dragons without warnings do you know how
cool both of these things are how are we
to choose which side we're rooting for
when there are dragons and super Birds I
like them both but also bringing an
eagle to a dragon fight also also scene
does not contain an elf exclaiming that
the eagle has landed no
we learned many words for
super great love the vocabulary can we
talk about the elves ability to get Icky
War gunk out of a beautiful white fabric
because Galadriel decided to wear her
favorite childhood dress pattern to the
middle of a darkened Battleground who
was the idiot that was like I'm putting
my dead friends helmet at the top of the
pile now watch as I Ascend the memories
of your recently murdered loved ones to
do it and mocked his flesh with a symbol
one whose meaning even our wisest could
not discern you should have asked me
it's clearly either a butt crack or an
apple because Aaron's absolutely an
[ __ ] boom translated
became mine stealing a dead person's
weapon without a will because if the
elves needed one more thing to contend
with it's the wind ripping them off the
side of this Cliff face using the capes
to kite them along don't wear capes
while scaling ice or anything really
this company has followed you to the
very edge of the world considering
yourself an educated Society but still
having people who believe the world has
edges
setting aside the paradoxical nature of
anyone ever saying we are there can we
chat a second about gladriel's plan
she's taking a fellowship of nine elves
to search out Sauron by just what
visiting that one place far up north and
even if sauron's here then what the
entirety of your armies couldn't do it
but you really think you plus Eight is
Enough I think we're supposed to respect
our gal pal for this Vengeance Quest but
honestly I think the line between
bravery and stupidity is firmly lilting
towards the side of the ladder
the door was filled in here but forget
understanding how she managed to spot it
behind the ice wall or how she managed
to punch it in just the right spot that
made a giveaway sheathing your sword
when you are most assuredly in danger
wasting your store of drinking water to
unlock the next clue in the escape room
when you could have all just peed on it
just as easily this Mark was left as a
trail for Orcs to follow but it's in a
side room designed for strange sorcery
so would that mean that every orc would
have to go into this room to know which
way to go and then do they go in the
direction of the longest point of the
symbol or the middle arrowy part of the
symbol I love gladriel's confidence and
she's not wrong but her leaps and logic
are astoundingly confusing oh of course
we have that one party member that
Strays away and Rouses trouble in a dark
place I guess we found our Pippin of the
group as badass as this looks I now have
to consider that someone literally
filmed these elves killing a cave troll
and that blood spatter tainted the lens
of their camera this means that inside
this moment there's an elf with a
[ __ ] video camera capturing footage
to edit together later which means that
none of this is real and I'm really
upset waiting till you're 30 done with
the episode to insert your title card
look what you've done drive my car look
what you've done also since when do
pilot episodes just not have theme songs
this is like a new trend and I hate it
not because I want more theme songs but
because you tease me with a world where
they don't exist and then take it all
away the very next week don't you think
it's the least bit strange that there
are no animals to hunt nope you're
wearing dead cartilage Kites on your
[ __ ] shoulders you can be seen and
smelled for miles away come on right
here Ducks dags are the bit of dried
feces that get caught in the butt wool
of sheep so when they speed up they
knock into each other and rattle so the
sin as always is noisy sheep
good thing this baby waited for the all
clear before crying out too bad they
didn't have that technology in The Quiet
Place movies being this aggressive with
sacred text these are Hobbits played by
actors which means this rabbit is either
CGI or insanely huge I had a quick look
around the interwebs which is very
dependable on facts and discovered that
the Flemish rabbit exists no rabbit
should be that big
discount Frodo and Sam okay fine there's
an 11 chance I will absolutely fall for
Nori and Poppy and adore them but that
doesn't mean I can't see that this show
is trying desperately to give me
stand-ins for all the characters and
PJ's movies it's 100 gonna work on me
but I'm still sitting it damn it the
centuries there swept cross cragged and
crevice they're reading your own speech
writing out loud to yourself like you're
a teenager making a diary entry on a CW
Show the tree care is not about your
fancy word smithery elrond and you are
immersed in a light more intoxicating
than any sensation in all of Middle
Earth when I was a child it was the only
feeling I knew and the anger
like Lisa melancholy
so gladriel's a liar I demand to speak
with the King directly well aren't you
full of your Elf a little elf confidence
is okay sure but this Alpha grandizing
elf righteous demand feels a bit Health
indulgent show some elf control and have
enough Health respect and not try and
cover up your low Alpha steam with his
elf absorbed ultimatum I honestly
thought all of this was elf explanatory
portable bee hives hang in the trees and
I'm just not sure how this community
would hide them when needed those poor
disrupted bees just trying to return to
their Queen and it's gone Hobbits are a
dick to bees I wonder if there's trouble
down south STDs even trees have to worry
about the soil beneath their Roots but
we harfoots are free from the worries of
the wide world I get that you live in
easy-going existence but how is your
farming for snails carrots and other
vegetation any different from a tree
worrying about the soil beneath their
Roots don't you also have to worry about
that soil and now it lost they returned
to us in Triumph for they have proven
Beyond any doubt that our days of War
are over mission accomplished speech
inches also glateriel came from valinor
because it was corrupted by morgoth how
does anyone know that valinor is a
blessed realm all these centuries later
has anyone that's gone back sent back a
report I really should write a book
about this world to explain some of this
stuff the undying lands of valinor at
last they are going home but if the
war's over and you all came over here
because of the war why hasn't everyone
headed back to valinor I know the king
knows there might be more to this story
but at the very least the rest of these
Coastal elf leads should be asking why
they aren't getting a ticket out of
Middle Earth America also elves clap
somehow this makes me despise them even
more after all you have endured it is
only natural to feel conflicted
conflicted did you just see what she did
with her lip that was astonishing watch
that again because I'm pretty sure she
does a lip curl double take to both
convey anger and surprise that kind of
lip control is completely unfair when I
can't even curl my lip at all put up
your sword without it what am I to be
you have always been my friend oh
cut us in three moves
[Music]
[Applause]
there buddy you don't just offer
Solutions into someone else's board game
that's an egregious break of competitive
fairness I still haven't forgiving my
uncle for walking by and telling my
sister she could play her draw four on
me back in 97. I think the show wants to
show us elves are smart but all I'm
seeing is that elves are [ __ ]
disrespecting your beverage like this
and for that matter just respecting the
table in the floor which are now wet and
need to be cleaned
quench the fire
I love how this bartender's super easy
going and chill until he gets a drink
knocked out of his hand and then he goes
full Rocky Balboa immediately but I
guess the show needed its good guy is
good guy to bad guy even as he's being a
bad guy to the good guy moment creating
armor that prevents your soldiers from
ever being able to say my eyes are a
peer buddy to anyone and you smell of
rotten leaves waiting this long to tell
your friend that their Bo is an
Abomination to your old factory what
were you before the war the grower hey
me too
oh he was saying he was a farmer wasn't
he uh look a cyclone Ops say what you
wish to say I have said it already 100
times over in every way but words around
here and there we like to use our words
like for instance skip greatest
development Smiths of course is about to
embark on a new project one of singular
importance
nudge nudge any of this ring any bells I
understand the great honor it is for
lateral inner Warriors to head to
greyhaven's blessed realm Far West
undying lands of valinor but what did
the others do during their spot in
forever ever land are they just
particularly good at d-robing people and
if that's the case would another elf
folk for all of the remainder of time
aspire to learn the art of synchronized
stripping to earn their place in donkey
in heaven and where is that movie I
don't care what version of sacred Elven
seagulls these birds are seagulls are
the worst and I'm sending them oh so
this whole thing is a setup for a horror
movie you're out in the ocean sailing
towards God knows what sperm birds fly
out of nowhere and surround the ship
then the company you're in burst into
simultaneous song as you race toward a
cloud that parts to reveal a light so
bright it consumes you this is
terrifying get it it's the tree people
from the movies are you not entertained
sometimes we cannot know until we have
touched the darkness wait that's the
advice that made you say but that seems
so simple earlier how is that simple
what does touching the darkness even
mean is the darkness tactile is it a
metaphor are we talking about touching
our body's own personal eye of Sauron
because I'm not even sure I can reach
back there huh I guess gladriel knew the
Eagles would come by later to save her
or something or is that with the
metaphor about looking upward was at the
beginning of this episode holy sh am I
rock well this looks [ __ ] incredible
and I'm Fanning out hoping this like
Gandalf's arrival to Middle Earth or
something I both want to sin this for
not telling me who this is so I can calm
myself down and also give us an offer
such a great way to end the first
episode the sin manual states that when
in this amount of conflict I must spend
20 minutes in sinful meditation and if
there's no resolution I must add 20 sins
for the wasted time surprise
boom River
thank you doc you ever serve time
how am I to know which lights to follow
people break down into two groups when
they experience something lucky group
number one sees it as more than luck
more than coincidence this is a sign
evidence that there is someone up there
watching out for them
[Music]
you all know the drill I'm not going to
pretend that what we're about to do
isn't reckless foolhardy even dangerous
but we will succeed because each of us
plays a vital role specifically tailored
to our individual talents look out look
out look out look out hero May 10th
thank God for the rain which has helped
wash away the garbage and the trash off
the sidewalks
don't conform your mind works in a
million different ways and now at last
they return to us in Triumph for they
have proven Beyond any doubt that our
days of War are over today we celebrate
our Independence Day when are you people
gonna let the past go what do you mean
you people so tell me
is it true
about your mum SWAT true
your mom was so stupid she thought Tupac
Shakur was a Jewish